Ah
Salve siamo qua Ma no ma vieni Marco
Ciao ragazzi Questo è un video veramente
super organizza questo è un video con
Marco
Eccolo qua Marco Marino signori sono
degli applausi sono oggi ho voluto fare
un video con il mio amico Marco
rispondiamo alle domande veramente molto
scomode che hanno fatto su Instagram un
Format già portato ma qua come puoi
vedere c'è uno schermone che ci aiuterà
in tutto questo ci aiuterà perché noi
proiettiamo lo schermo proprio le
domande ne scegliamo una testa io La
scelgo per pretura e fine
[Musica]
Favij Originals però lo voglio fare con
te questo video perché so che tu sei
estremamente sincero sempre in più mi fa
ridere il fatto che a volte la sincerità
può far stare male qualcuno di quelli
che ascoltano
cominciamo
[Musica]
voi cosa ne pensavi del sesso da bambino
Io ho trovato una stranissima cassetta
quando ero piccolo era un porno
probabilmente era di mio padre perché
mia madre era molto una suora amatoriale
ho detto quindi due persone possono fare
questa cosa qui assieme però nessuno la
fa delle persone vicino a me non l'ho
mai vista quindi la mia idea era c'è
molto di più da imparare nella vita
molto figo è molto interessante che io
avevo trovato queste VHS nello stesso
mucchio dove c'erano anche quelle Disney
io la prima volta che ho avuto un
avvicinamento al mondo sessuale ho
trovato io ai tempi non c'era Non
avevamo tutti i telefonini e avevo ogni
tanto rubavo con il mio padre avevo
trovato delle gif tipo c'era questa
angioletto che è un angioletto donna che
questo diavoletto maschio piccolo Wow Te
la ricordi
bravissima no possiamo mostrarci No no
sì Come cazzo hai fatto bravissimo c'è
un passato tantissimo tempo veramente
bravissimo
penso che sia sempre in ambito
relazioni o cose così perché per me
conta molto questa domanda che mi faccio
è però non devi rispondere
la risposta Che domanda vuoi È solo la
domanda non devi rispondere alla domanda
che ti fai
[Musica]
hai mai rischiato di avere un bambino
hai mai cercato se le dimensioni del tuo
bene fossero nella media certo non l'ha
fatto non l'ho fatto
ti è mai capitato di sentirti in debito
con qualcuno anche sapendo di non
esserlo Sicuramente sì allora ci sono
delle situazioni in cui io mi sento in
debito perché mi faccio troppi problemi
per le altre persone e quindi magari
quello non gliene frega neanche più un
cazzo di quella cosa esattamente questo
esatto Io ho un problema io mi sento in
debito costantemente quando vado a cena
con qualcuno perché mi sento che io devo
Non so se tu hai questa cosa
interessante a te viene mai da pagare ad
una persona perché magari tu sai che tu
Sì certo sempre io mi sento indebito
costantemente ogni volta che vado a cena
no debito No però lo faccio quando mi
chiedono perché molte volte lo faccio
anche con le fidanzatine loro credono
sia Cavalleria No sono più ricco di
Debby Sono completamente d'accordo con
questo che stai dicendo Ma io non solo
con le tipe
tanto abbiamo fatto questo discorso con
la persona che usufruisce di più di
questo se tu fossi una sedia chi faresti
sedere su di te se io fossi una sedia
tantissime persone Felix schalberg
Sostanzialmente è una persona che ha
sorretto un po' Ma tu l'aveva incontrato
No però questo guarda questo è il mio
libro e questi sono per prima non ho mai
pubblicato questa foto cioè ai tempi che
è uscito il mio libro sembrava che
volessi sponsorizzare il mio libro così
non me ne fregava un cazzo di Natale
semplicemente loro hanno avevano un
qualcosa di mio e mi rendeva felice
Quindi non l'ho mai pubblicata ma me la
sono sempre tutte in galleria c'era
ancora Vorrei sorreggere Felix io ho
reso
ma non per qualcosa hai mai la
sensazione di avere dato tutto ciò che
potevi di esserti lasciato alle spalle
il meglio di te
is this the real life Il fatto è questo
che questa domanda è spaziale perché
dare tutto ciò che potevo non deve per
forza coincidere con
dare il meglio che potevi non deve
coprire con hai lasciato il meglio di te
no Comunque io mi sento di dire che
spesso ho la sensazione di vivere gli
anni più belli della mia vita succede da
anni e quindi mi sento di
dover Ogni giorno fare ogni giorno
doverlo vivere al meglio perché so che
domani non sarà più così quindi il
meglio di me oggi è il meglio di me
anche domani ma un po' meno eh Ma questo
è un pensiero per il futuro non per il
passato sta domanda qua è molto perché
io guardo il futuro come se fosse il
presente mentre invece questa persona
questa persona qua Parla un po' di un
passato straziato sì sì no E infatti un
po' come dicevo Linkin Park cazzo fai in
the end in Doesn't Matter
Questo è un evento che è cambiato il tuo
modo di vivere Diciamo che quando ho
iniziato a essere riconosciuto per
strada ho dovuto necessariamente
cambiare perché sennò avrei vissuto una
vita terrificante perché essere
riconosciute effettivamente in giro per
una persona timida e un problema pian
piano ho dovuto dire bene la mia vita
sarà questa per sempre che io non
schiavo impararlo perché io lo imparo o
mi ammazzo quindi sì ho imparato questo
e questa è stata la prima volta c'è
anche una seconda un anno e mezzo fa ero
un periodo molto brutto te lo ricordi
forse anche te ne avevo parlato in
depressione Cioè ho fatto un percorso
che mi ha aiutato appunto a riprendermi
dalla depressione c'è un percorso
psicologico ma presto ha cambiato il
modo di vedere le cose ultimamente
Quindi tutto questo dal mero essere
riconosciuto assolutamente migliore la
cosa più imbarazzante su cui ti sei
che è uscita ufficialmente in chiave un
po' erotica su Playboy
Minchia se stai cercando adesso cerca e
troverai lei la migliore è quella che
sta lavando a terra e ha un po' il la
pettorina è bagnata da acqua e quindi si
intravede questo capezzolo della
pazzesco comunque vedere Mario Simpson
che è stata la tua seconda mamma nuda a
un certo punto è stato strano Ok io mi
ricordo il Come si chiama Dame a me
amasutra
è un classicone
la si parla di fierezza domanda banale
ma allo stesso tempo che tutti
dovrebbero un po' farsi Creator almeno
quando hai deciso di fare nuove Format
avevi paura che la gente non fosse
contento No perché quando ho cambiato
Format ho sostanzialmente deciso non
stavo più facendo questo per la gente ma
lo stavo facendo per me che era la cosa
che aveva funzionato all'inizio cioè io
all'inizio ho fatto quello che stavo
facendo il gameplay per me ho capito che
la chiave migliore per vincere nella
vita Sostanzialmente è ascoltarsi ed è
quello che ho fatto perché poi trasmetti
tutto quello che è il tuo divertimento
agli altri quindi quello che sto facendo
adesso è quello che mi piace piace alle
persone giuste ci piace le persone alle
quali voglio arrivare non piace le
persone alle quali non voglio arrivare
quindi tutto giusto Non sono per niente
spaventato né dei numeri né niente anche
perché quando si cambia di solito in
questi percorsi qua poi un po' la
consapevolezza che la gente è
palesemente non rimarrà contenta o
comunque ci sarà sempre un filo
delusione Beh certo i loro pensieri in
una maniera un po' Severa e grezza devi
pensare più a chi arriva dopo e meno a
quelli che ti seguiranno da prima perché
nonostante ci saranno sempre quelli che
dicono guarda Lorenzo Marco Vi saluto
fin dall'inizio anche se siete cambiati
però saranno sempre di più quelli nuovi
che troverai cambiando che quelli vecchi
che rimarranno per quanto sia
Tristissimo sono molto d'accordo bene
questa era le domande scomode ehm di
oggi Fatemi sapere se volete un altro
video del genere è sempre tutto in testa
qua e abbiamo testato anche il programma
per il telefono vabbè ci vediamo eh non
so ci diamo alla prossima volta raga